sushi a traditional Japanese food with
an international appeal and in the West
fewer associated with it more than this
man Nobu Matsuhisa he's been dishing up
high-end Japanese cuisine to the rich
and famous by fusing raw fish with South
American flavors going from chef to
entrepreneur he opened his own brand of
restaurants in New York 20 years ago
backed by a Hollywood a-list business
partner when was the moment he said we
looked at Robert De Niro and he went I
trust him it's all about De Niro's has
came to the my lesser then he asked me
to come to opening the New York and
together with the partnerships so first
time the he offered to me I said no
thank you I cannot do it then after four
years he asked me again so means Wow
it's of course he's a big star and now I
can transfer you because partnership is
in selected the trust each other's he
understand my philosophies and that
philosophy gave birth to an
international business 32 restaurants in
28 different cities but it hasn't all
been easy sometimes I got opened my
lesson in Alaska Sofia came out one down
lot of people supported me included my
my family maybe I didn't they give up
also always I like to try my best
overcoming this setback not only did
Matsuhisa go on to become a celebrity
sushi master but also a Las Vegas hotel
owner so the needle asked me to like an
OB it's not why we do the lesson in that
somebody's hotel why do we not to do
record on over there you know so idea
come from him what happens in Vegas
doesn't necessarily stay in Vegas so
second one it's coming this year and the
Philippines and Saudi Arabia so end of
the year is going to be the Miami than
the hotel so it looks like for Nobu the
greatest skill has been turning raw fish
into raw success
you